salut quatrième jour ensemble quatrième
joueur sur le rubik's cube
on touche le bout les amis vous allez
bientôt savoir faire le rubik's cube
entièrement en cinq formules en moins de
deux minutes
hier on s'est quitté là dessus le
premier jour vous avez appris à faire la
face la première couronne deuxième jour
la deuxième couronne troisième jour vous
avez appris à faire la croix sur le
dessus on est presque au bout il nous en
reste 8 à placer et aujourd'hui on va
apprendre à remplacer quatre d'un coup
en l'occurrence la croix à l'évoquer ce
qui est pas ok par contre c'est les
correspondances avec la deuxième
couronne ça c'est pas bon et même si on
continuait de tourner comme ça se serait
jamais bon de tous les côtés il nous
faut donc une nouvelle formule pour ça
et ça tombe bien je les ai évidemment et
cette formule là elle est très
intéressante parce qu'elle va vous
servir également à la dernière étape
donc c'est une formule qui va vous
servir deux fois elle va nous permettre
de faire un saut de mouton entre les
cubes je passe derrière pour mieux vous
expliquer lille est la suivante on va
faire un saut de mouton avec les phases
des cubes mais un d'entre eux va rester
fixe le orange est bien positionné par
rapport à la deuxième couronne le vert
va faire un soutenu ton jusque-là à sa
position le rouge va lui aussi se
décaler ici à sa position et le bleu va
se décaler la à sa position celui ci
restera toujours fixe quand on tient le
remix devant soi ce cube là restera fixe
donc ça fait passer celui-ci en face lui
juste à sa droite
et oui juste à sa droite également la
formule c'est droite aux droites
inversée au droite haut à droite
inversée au mot art dit comme ça c'est
pas évident à retenir au lieu de dire oh
oh je pense à achkhar et moi dans ma
tête et si simplifie encore dans ma tête
ça donne des hd inversée hdh carré d
inverser h car cette formule là elle est
très simple à se mettre dans les doigts
je vous fais voir donc j'ai positionné
une couleur face à la deuxième couronne
je me mets en face et c'est parti droite
aux droites inversée au droite au carré
droite inversée au carré et on vérifie
le bleu est bien en phase et le deuxième
couronne idem pour le orange
idem pour le vert idem pour le rouge on
a protégé les deux couronnes en à
protéger cette phase et on a protégé
notre croix tout ça ça n'a pas bougé
mais qu'est-ce qui se passerait si on
s'était trompé au départ mais je vais
vous faire voir j'ai annulé ce que je
veux faire donc pour annuler
voilà là je vient d'annuler ce qu'on
vient de faire si au départ j'avais mis
en place le vert donc dans ces cas là le
bleu va passer sur le rouge le orange au
bleu et le rouge ou orange
donc on regarde ce qui se passe donc il
s'est passé un décalage mais pas le bon
c'est pas très grave si je le rappeler
qu'une deuxième fois ça va placer le bon
décalage donc droite aux droites
inversée au droite au carré droite
l'inversé au carré en clair ne vous
inquiétez pas si votre positionnement de
départ était pas bon si vous le thonier
pas dans le bon sens dans ces cas là ne
bougeait pas ré appliquer la formule une
fois deux fois autant de fois que
nécessaire mais obligatoirement avec ce
décalage et se saute mouton vous allez à
un moment donné tomber sur la bonne
position il n'y a pas le choix c'est
comme ça c'est mathématique et si on
regarde bien comme promis vous en avez
quatre de plus de bien positionner donc
il y en a plus que quatre à mettre en
place les quatre angles une fois qu'on
aura mis ces quatre là en place on aura
terminé ce rubik's cube
on s'arrête là pour aujourd'hui
entraînez-vous bien sûr cette formule
vous aidiez à va nous servir pas dans la
prochaine vidéo mais dans celle d'après
et essayer au lieu de l'apprendre par
coeur de bien l'assimilé dans les doigts
oui elle est pas désagréable à faire
c'est une formule agréable à appliquer
fait un focus sur cette formule jusqu'à
demain vous ne vous entraînez casse à
oublier tout le reste pour le moment
entraînez-vous à cette formule cette
formule cette formule alors bon
entraînement et rendez vous demain à 17
heures pour le prochain mentale blog
ciao